[Music]
in my hero news
Oh Piersol submitted by English for less
I don't know things on a theme park is
offering a fight with bad guy service
guess I'll walk out of here so guests
can impress defendant oh that is so
[ __ ] Pokemon of dota
so you're just rocking up and a butter
yaku that come up any piece of [ __ ] iron
of your group and I'm a Riddler and then
you come up I don't see yous are
knocking everybody out of whatever video
no I want it yeah sorry about that
yo this is the best thing I've ever seen
in my life oh you girls are gone oh [ __ ]
hold on what you packing ready to sing
come cut the crusts off so mom oh I
almost miss real you know Paul is a
really crazy as [ __ ] Tina don't you know
what that reminds me of Nacho Libre yeah
one scene wait hey can't you see she's a
nun you know I [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
I've ever been on that literate dude
that's a part of his heritage that's why
I'm watching that non-stop ah dude that
movie is probably the most quotable
movie in the history of movies because
sergeant they were the Lord's tips I
don't believe in what if I don't believe
in Jesus I believe a sign you had a
friend that looked exactly like him he
had the same mouth with everything
so did I actually hear you mention it Oh
crazy say his name another three one
Tuesday
I remember his name yeah so at this
theme park in Osaka he I've got that
part they're offering this service along
with other services if you're not into
beating up actors you can also just use
a fake bomb oh my god this is the dopest
thing I've ever heard in my life
swap the bodies at the stranger what do
you think I don't know or offer their
blood to someone who urges Lee needs a
transfusion and that gets you [ __ ] in
Japan apparently
this is lost even though everyone knows
this be the services that depart I
thought it was like some discrete [ __ ]
like oh yeah he doesn't know yeah a
little bit yeah they're saying that
before they actually go up to you and
you have to pretend to fight with them
before that you have to take like a
little mini reharsal
yeah like a quick rehearsal type of
thing so you guys can make sure that
you're in sync with a hiss and all that
stuff and they're saying that the show
lasts about 10 minutes oh [ __ ] that's a
good show
yeah so there's going to be like bad sir
there's gonna be like dialog legit for a
walk by slappy girl's ass you sure I
don't know it's like I can touch my
property
oh now actually went a little sour okay
look at somebody like that ice cream
they pretty much make it seem so your
date doesn't know what's happening
beforehand the one it does happen it
seems like this Jenny I feel bad for the
guy that goes to the rehearsal and he
still gets exactly like it's supposed to
be all the way around and then now you
really isn't gonna get any Japanese
person Oh what if your girl is like she
just was out as soon as it goes down
yeah
and she kicks to do that right crazy
there's been a b6 do you know it work on
you ladies oh no one works on this [ __ ]
she loved that much evil oh yeah that's
true you do love that fighting like
straight up if Bart was surrounded and
bars like this but this babe get your
pregnant [ __ ] after the bag I got this
[ __ ] you like yeah
not look a letter I was laughing at me
the way you would move Z when he was
going brilliant with it
uh I mean now in this face no cuz then
I'm just like I don't want him again in
like danger no but this is a situation
that you cannot avoid think about in a
moment I wouldn't want that but
afterwards if you winds like oh that's
oh baby you know that time when you
[ __ ] Josh's eyeballs out you had on
your fingers like this it was so I was
just happen to realize and you do get
beat the [ __ ] up
fascist [ __ ] liar but it's multiple
guys do you look at him different and
it's most no that's not fair if it's
just one if it's a little one he could
beat the bugger a little bit so now if
you try sex all brands like I got you
like naughty don't it's all right he was
an enemy fighter look him up look I
follow my Instagram kick man you're like
that Taichi guy after I got my ass beat
I'll just wake up stupid you know my
[ __ ] shoes were slippery right God
he's fluff you're lucky dude that I have
a white face this is my face is small he
would've hit me once
ops to dangers from yeah how could do
dangerous man I was worried about his
life I usually work on you computer like
it's wrong you send your own ground we
go work on it in shooting further but
the [ __ ] up man I got it
don't worry Peter I only work on me if
it was really genuine like if the
situation was genuine were like we were
in a life-threatening situation
but if it was like some sort of setup or
like if I could kind of tell that this
dude is a little bit too relaxed and was
like you don't worry I got this I'm
coming but yeah I know in a real life
situation they're like completely turned
on by it so does this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] guy walks up slaps your ass yeah
and then your boyfriend's like - yeah
hey coop turn around
buddy you know
and also he dukes out he starts knocking
Duke Valley and after what you'd like
you buy the gifts of a dish tonight
probably
has anyone ever has anyone ever grabbed
your ass grab my ass you I feel like
she'd be really quiet I don't think they
should be like what's up what [ __ ] I
don't know honey I will be anyways run
my ass but like if anyone were to like
touch me out of nowhere
I do remember my initial reaction been
like what applause oh they weren't
watching me and it's like but I don't I
don't I remember anyone like seriously
groping my ass I'm a stranger what
you're just thinking to play yeah you
just chillin yeah you know there's um
there's a Pikachu that's who yeah I know
yeah okay okay well a quiet okay yeah
you're the quiet one you are quiet but
that's effective that's a second bilko
right oh man Canadian if you persisted
that I would be louder other like what
the [ __ ] dude okay that's the personal
this is the second one yeah hey come on
[ __ ] you back off hey oh that's good I
like that
I believe it I like that I'm not sure
about you though you're a little bit oh
your little other words what tell on the
words cuz I don't defend myself I don't
say many don't say that yes he does no I
think no I honestly I think now I'm a
lot better than I was in the past when I
have in grabs when I was a college grad
her nickname is too late happen in too
deep so it'll happen with her in our
situation back in the day not the new
tip that will come up and touch her for
some reason don't get married and then
[ __ ] you know seven years later she'll
be like what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me but she
did you deep by that point there
that's what they want me in foody doing
she has stuff that she knows that she
wants to say but it doesn't come out no
I think that's I'm better those oh yeah
they've helped me get better okay I got
a question let's say you're by yourself
no boyfriend
ooh some creep comes creeping and a
random dude jumps in it fights it oh is
it cute is he my age excitable you're a
how many single yeah your age he's
single not sexy but not the average guy
yeah and you guys are single this I
would talk to him I think he's give a
viola average looking guy single but he
got ugly pants and shoes hmm are you can
change that yeah how is that it what he
loves me look at Casey case in point she
likes him she made greasy has long hair
when we let us right but he was never
ugly oh yeah extra because I know that
ugly she would be deterring people like
a [ __ ]
you could can't yet I'm not sure about
those shoes I mean all I do that's the
first thing I only wanna go got beat up
shoes I'm not your clothes must be funny
to see I hate that that's a thing now
like having your shoes beat up imitation
yeah because I came up into generation
yes you had to be clean okay [ __ ]
clean son wow wow
you are shoes determine your overall
taste in general if you have wax shoes
you're going to buy a wax car going to
buy a lap house and have what last
closing ordained wax six yeah that's
true my shoes tells you everything
chooser and shoes are really important
oh you're a beauty busted but they got
really dope shoes you're like okay
that's on purpose then what about Chuck
because I grew up in the same time where
a truck I mean all the shoes maybe cream
I'll greet what the Chuck they have to
be really clean I'll tell you the rule
oh I'll tell you the rule on the trucks
hmm with clean for where's chucks
okay so chucks are okay but
[Laughter]
what's Khalifa but SKS they wear them
every single day and those are the only
pair of shoes they have didn't know
they're just being lazy but if they
bring chucks in and out they got other
shoes okay mmm I guess I meant more for
the cleanliness because when I was in
high school like having clean like
sparkling Chuck's worth the [ __ ] yeah
Batman oh yeah not good nowadays your
chucks and vans were supposed to me yeah
but I never I never got down Chuck so
hard for me to buy because like I
remember back in the day you remember a
[ __ ] East Bay yeah yeah they should
sell chucks straight up no joke three
for $25
they were that [ __ ] [ __ ] Mary Jane
hello Chuck and they got popular and
suddenly they're 60 bucks a pair Mike
you gotta be kidding me
yeah that's what about me now yeah they
added the [ __ ] Luna La Paz and Ikey
bought them out but you still man I
usually get three for 25 bucks come on
now that's also I don't like tux I like
sewing the floor on my feet
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode if you haven't already make sure
to hit that subscribe button because we
upload videos every single day for you
guys now to watch more videos check them
out of here
[Music]